on monday a horrifying clip from a
recently released hbo documentary went
viral
in the scene congregants at a unitarian
universalist church
are invited by the female pastor to
quote
proclaim their identity publicly as
lesbian gay bisexual transgender queer
queer or questioning intersex pansexual
asexual
or any category i've left out unquote a
mother then
pulls her young son four years old it
turns out onto the stage to announce
that he's really a girl
but the poor child has no interest in
being paraded around like his
mother's show pony so he hands the
microphone back
saying that he doesn't want to do it the
mother takes it upon herself to
come out on her son's behalf informing
the audience that her son phoenix
would quote like you to know that she's
a girl and she prefers
she and her pronouns completing this
apparently familiar ritual the pastor
hands the child a pink flower as the
congregation repeats its creepy
affirmation in unif unison
uh quote may you be well safe and whole
we honor you exactly as you are of
course
that's the exact opposite of what
they're really doing
this isn't even the worst scene in hbo's
transhood documentary which is now
available
on their streaming platform the film
follows four transgender children
over the course of five years it's
clearly meant to promote
and normalize the deranged sort of child
abuse just described
but any rational person who subjects
themselves to the film
which i did but i wouldn't recommend it
will come away with a number of
important insights that the filmmakers
did not intend phoenix's case is
i think especially instructive before
the forced coming out party
we see the boy in a dress in a different
scene on a bed
filled with lots of pink and rainbow
colored things
and he's being read a book called
jacob's new dress by his mother
uh here's that scene if you can stomach
it then we slid
into a shiny yellow dress while jacob
wiggled into a sparkly pink dress
what are you wearing esteban it's like a
dress
i made it dad brown you can't go to
school like that
put on some shorts and a shirt under
that just thing mom said and hurry we're
late for school you're never late for
school right
because you're almost cold let's get the
sewing machine
she said finally jacob felt the air
refill his body
he grinned mom smiled back there are all
sorts of ways to be a boy
she said right wait i'm going through
them
and also caring about them and i'm also
wearing
girl clothes you are wearing they are
your clothes so they are boy clothes
dad looked up from his butt okay those
are girl clubs
i am a girl boy next in an interview
um the mother molly tells us that
phoenix is quote
gender expansive non-binary gender
non-conforming
gender awesome under the trans umbrella
girl boy and rainbow boy all of those
things
before finally concluding that quote we
don't really have a good term
well i have a really good term it's
called boy
now for his part the father zach mostly
sits quietly a common theme in the film
which we'll return to in a moment but
he agrees that his son's gender is
somehow quote up in the air right
now eventually phoenix who never at
any point shows any strong desire to be
a girl
and appears to be mostly confused and
bored with the whole thing
is nonetheless socially transitioned
into one
but the years pass and phoenix continues
in the nasty habit of being a boy
despite his parents insisting otherwise
eventually they get divorced another
common theme
and decide that never mind actually
their son is a boy after all turns out
but the good news is that molly feels
better at the end because she's
worked through her issues and is
starting a new leaf
where we are not exactly told how her
son really feels about having his gender
switch back and forth
while his home life is ripped in two as
parents give up on their marriage
his feelings and well-being appear to be
more of an afterthought amid his
mother's
psychodrama shades of the phoenix story
can be easily detected in the other
three
trans kid profiles there's jay age
12 when filming begins uh she's a girl
making the quote transition into a boy
her father doesn't appear to be in the
picture at all
i don't think we see him at all but her
mother bryce is a lesbian who eventually
meets and marries a defensive lineman
from the local women's football league
we're first introduced to jay when she's
being given her first hormone blocker
injection
before the onset of puberty later she
goes into surgery to have a blocker
implanted in her body
bryce the mother seems unsure even at
times distraught by all this
but she goes along with it and funds it
and facilitates it
every step of the way similar dynamic
with lena 15 years old the beginning of
the film
also just beginning the medical
transition in this case from boy to girl
we meet lena and his divorced father
mike
as the two are out bikini shopping for
the young man
we learned that mike had his hesitations
about the transgender thing when lena
first announced his gender confusion
around the time of the parents divorce
nine years prior there's that theme
again
but has since learned to accept it and
now his sons or his
daughters ambition is to become a
victorious secret model and mike along
with his ex-wife
accompanied lena to his first modeling
tryout
by the end of the film lena has decided
to take it all the way um
going under the surgeon's knife the
surgeon is also transgender
to make his physical transition
permanent and basically irreversible
the most disturbing story of all is that
of seven-year-old avery
he's a boy who according to his parents
is
really deep down a girl avery's mother
debbie traipses the child
all around the country doing media
interviews attending marches
rallies etc the cameras catch the
moments when debbie
informs avery that he'll be quote
writing a transaffirming children's book
and then going on a book tour against
his will he doesn't want to do it
and also when debbie tells avery that a
national geographic photographer
will be arriving shortly to take
pictures for the magazine's upcoming
cover story on gender avery is
visibly and audibly unhappy with all of
this
all throughout the entire uh film he
objects to
all of his mother's schemes and at one
point late in the film
upon hearing that he'll be forced to
attend yet another lgbt rally in dc
says that his life is ruined and voices
a level of exhaustion and weariness that
no child should ever experience let me
play that scene for you now
we're going to washington d.c and we're
going to be
moving to the white house for central
area to
throw a book in donald trump's face no i
don't think that we want to say that
no this one is time to thrive and it's
for
people who work with lgbtq youth we
actually go
and meet with our senators some
representatives
after we do that we go and sit
and sell some of avery's books for a
little while
avery manners i just don't want to even
have a book
i've done too much in this world it's
ruined my life enough and now
everyone in this world is going to know
if i sell my book it's going to get on
the news like
with along with me for like the 50th
time at this point
and it's just gonna make my life worse a
couple years ago you wanted people to
know
yeah i i did but now that was really
stupid silly mistake and now i don't
[Music]
yeah that's something let's go back now
avery doesn't seem too invested in this
female persona
minus the long neon colored hair and the
overcompensating rainbow outfits that
his mother puts him in
he comes across like a relatively normal
young boy
debbie noticing this with some level of
alarm decides that avery is just a quote
tomboy trans girl yes
that would be a boy who is a girl who
acts like a boy
as for avery's father and his view of
everything it's never made entirely
clear
like the other fathers in the film he's
basically a useless lump of nothingness
floating along with the tide
while his wife psychologically and
physically destroys his son
in order to satisfy her own unquenchable
narcissism these men are literally
watching their sons be turned into girls
and that's one of the ingredients that
is always present whenever a young boy
is forced to sacrifice his masculinity
in this way
they always have fathers who have
already willingly sacrificed their own
that is a necessary ingredient
and that is one of the important lessons
the film doesn't want to teach us but
does anyway
there is no mystery to the transness of
avery phoenix lena or jay
or any trans child in avery's case his
mother
has it would seem very clearly imposed a
trans identity onto him
monchausen syndrome by proxy is a known
mental illness
where a parent usually a mother pretends
that their child is sick or sometimes
even causes the child to be sick in
order to
gain sympathy and attention for
themselves from the public
if the psychiatric industry was at all
honest and trustworthy debbie would be
diagnosed with this disorder
and her children removed from her care
for their own safety as it happens
though
as the film clearly portrays doctors and
therapists are much more likely to feed
into this kind of mania than to diagnose
and treat it
that's the other piece of the puzzle
that removes any mystery from the trans
epidemic among children
the entire medical field with very rare
exception has bought into this radical
left-wing gender theory
a gender-confused child with a parent
like
debbie stands no chance he will find
no help no protection from his
pediatricians or his therapist or his
school
they're just going to send them off to
be drugged mutilated and further abused
but not all trans kids have parents like
debbie
the other kids in transhood seem to have
mothers and fathers who are perhaps less
exploitative
than they are confused and competent and
self-absorbed
all throughout the documentary we
constantly see
the parents turning to their kids and
asking
them for direction relying on their
children to take the lead
asking them what do you want to do how
are you feeling how do you
identify you tell us putting it all on
them on their shoulders
the burden of leadership placing it on
their five-year-old son's shoulders
phoenix's dad gives the closest thing we
hear to a fatherly lecture in the whole
uh the whole film telling his
son-turned-daughter turned son
that it's okay that he was a girl before
and it's okay that he's a boy now
and it's okay if he's a girl later and
really it's all up to him
well gee thanks for the advice pop very
clarifying
like any other child phoenix desperately
needs direction
and leadership and clarity what he gets
and said instead are shrugging shoulders
and his pathetic hen pecked father's
refusal to offer any guidance of any
kind whatsoever
so it's up to phoenix to figure out who
he is
what reality is what anything is
his parents will provide nothing to the
child except food a bed a roof
and a bunch of pretty dresses should he
decide he wants to wear them other than
that
the boy's on his own and that's how you
end up with transgender children
of course the documentary wants us to
learn a different lesson in the epilogue
before the credits roll
the last thing we're told is that lena
um right after waking up from his as
they call it in orwellian speak
gender affirmation surgery supposedly
turned to his mother and whispered
i'm free now i doubt whether he said
that at all but if he did
it was yet another expression of the
tragic confusion
that has plagued this kid since early
childhood he is not free
now that he has rejected himself and his
own biological nature in a way that can
never
really be undone but that is another
lesson
he'll have to learn on his own with no
help from his parents
and the sad thing is that when he does
like so many other kids
it'll be too late hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated